foreign
I've been married for 16 years and I've
got two boys and my husband he's a good
husband but he's not a great dad he's
just very emotionally unavailable I feel
like I have a responsibility to him to
help him grow into the best person that
he can be you can't help him be better
[Music]
hip-hop you don't stop what's up this is
John with the Dr John deloney show I
don't even really listen to hip-hop that
much I used to a lot but I don't much
anymore
Kelly is a huge fan
not so much no I like I mean come on I'm
in 80s 90s kid so I love me some good
good old school hip-hop yeah Come On
Eileen all right hey we're so glad that
you're here on the greatest it's not
hip-hop that's not hip hop in any way
shape or form I know come on up but one
of my favorite 80s songs ever though is
it it is I don't know why it's just a
fun song and a great one-hit wonder a
Ska band redid it
um and I forgot their name I saw them
open up a real big fish it was fantastic
and now I feel bad that I don't remember
their name but they had a one hit what
does that make you if you're you're one
hit wonder is a cover of another band's
one hit wonder
I don't know that makes this makes for a
fun year in your 20s and then it kind of
goes away but anyway thanks for joining
us on the greatest podcast ever when it
comes to mental health marriage and
relationships and if I say it long
enough I just think it'll be true like
our politicians do
um listen if you uh want to
help out the podcast
um please
mostly help out the podcast I mean for
in all seriousness who cares it's really
about helping out your neighbors
um help them get the care they need the
questions they need
I'm gonna tell the truth I'm gonna walk
alongside you I'm gonna love you more
than I'm gonna throw stuff at you so it
you can really help us out you can
really help out your neighbor by just
adding your five star reviews hitting
the Subscribe button it's such a gift so
thank you for everyone who's doing that
um it helps spin the show up in the
algorithms and helps puts it in front of
more people that need that help so thank
you very very much
and if you're somebody who takes
supplements or I've been considering
supplements I've partnered with the
greatest supplement company on the
planet Thorne
t-h-o-r-n-e and we've partnered to give
you 25 off everything in the store
everything in the store they're the best
supplements on the market they're what I
take they're what my kids take what my
wife takes
um I've got all my friends take I mean
they're just the best and so go to
thorn.com you the letter U slash deloni
thorn.com
and get your supplements there they'll
ship them to your house and they're the
best of the best of the best all right
let's go to Holly in Kansas City
Missouri what's up Holly
hi Dr John how we doing
oh I'm so excited to talk to you I'm
excited to talk to you and Patrick
Mahomes way to go all right so what's up
um okay so my question for you is where
do you draw the line between your
responsibility to your spouse and your
responsibility to your kids
um and I can give you some context
around that give me some context
okay so I've been married for 16 years
and I've got two boys and my husband
he's a good husband how old are they but
he's not a great dad
um 14 and 12. 14 and 12. and Hey I was
talking over the top of you and I
apologize you said something profound
say it again
I said he's a good husband but he's not
a great dad
unpack that for me
so he's
well I feel very obligated to stay at
the LSAT like no abuse or anything like
that he's just very emotionally
unavailable okay
um maybe emotionally immature even
and
I feel like I have a responsibility to
him to help him grow into the best
person that he can be and I love him
dearly but I feel like I also have a
responsibility to raise boys who will be
good Dads and if they model off of him I
don't think that will be
um successful so you can't help him be
better he has to choose to be better
you can assist him you can walk
alongside him you can help meet his
needs if he is of the emotional maturity
to speak them out loud and he has a
vested interest in also meeting your
needs you can do that
um you can't help him be the best dad he
can be he has to choose that he wants to
be a better dad
when you've brought this up to him in
the past how has he responded
families are and I get jealous of oh
that's Dangerous Ground Holly
that's super Dangerous Ground
um because in Reverse him saying
um man I see how other wives take care
of themselves I just some gel like you
write you see how that can get real
sideways real fast so give me some
examples let's take other people's lives
off the table because no matter what you
think you're just getting a curated
version of that world
what are some things that you see in
your life that you think make him not a
good dad
he doesn't play with our kids he has
never really played with our kids he
really kind of
only interacts with him to like give
them chores or something like that it's
not a
like it's almost a sequence spoken to
not really trying to make them into the
adults he wants them to be more of
enforce the children he wants to have
okay so he's more concerned with don't
bother me stay out of my way I can give
you your life and I give you food in a
bed get away see what you're told don't
ask questions if I say no I say no that
sort of stuff okay and he doesn't take
them those those kind of speak when
spoken to you do what I say those type
of
that type of parenting only works in a
relationship right when there's a
context there
um do they miss their dad do they even
try to interact with them or they just
moved on
they just moved on they come to me for
things or like they'll ask me to ask him
questions but I don't think he knows
that they do that
so hard question for you
where was this conversation 12 years ago
it wasn't as bad then okay
um it just seems like it's gotten worse
and worse as time goes on does he not
like them do they just did they freak
him out do they scare him what's he
what's he trying to protect himself from
I think
he doesn't I I think that's more of an
inward thing than an outward thing what
does that mean like I think he doesn't
like himself
okay and so because of that he just
Retreats further and further into
himself how's your marriage
um you know we're going we're working on
some stuff like I think most people are
that was a that was not even a good
evasive answer how's your marriage
Teddy's a great husband I'm calling BS
no he
he for me
um so he'll change your tire he'll
change your tire that's cool and he
makes sure the oils change which is
awesome and he does pay bills cool
um is that the standard by which we were
saying he's a great husband now
um well he's really starting to put in
some effort to become not just the
husband he wants to be but the husband I
need and I respect that and in giving
him time to you know rise to the
excision okay
um you have bifurcated a man into two
different roles
he's a husband over here and he's a dad
over here
I would say those are relationships
that emanate from the same person
and in many ways those can be different
skill sets and different different tools
that I've got to pick up along the way
and learn right I've never parented a 12
year old before in my house and so I'm
having to learn in real time what that
what that's like
um but it's worth the effort right I've
never I've never parented a six-year-old
girl and good God Almighty I don't know
what I'm doing and but I'm giving it my
best shot from reading and learning and
talking to wise people and saying I'm
sorry and asking for advice and wisdom
right and more most above all else I'm
leaning into that relationship is weird
and awkward as both of them can be
your husband isn't a great dad and a bad
husband or a bad husband and a great dad
um he's a man who's really struggling
and he might perform better on one task
and he's not performing well on the
other but he may be
trying to get better in one relationship
but abandoning other relationships this
comes from the same guy
and I say that because if he got the
parent the husbanding thing down great
and he's a completely neglects his kids
he's never going to be there right
you're never going to fully lean into
that
you shouldn't right so
man this is hard because I know he I can
almost guarantee he would have a another
side of the story
um
well that's why I guess my question is I
I don't really know
how do you choose or when do you face a
line where you have to choose because
I've heard callers call into your show
before and say things like I wish I
would have done something differently
and I just don't want to be in a
position that I wish I would have done
something sooner or later to have you
know
that's a great great question
um and I'm trying to be sensitive to my
own home and keep some space between
intensely private things in my house and
also be open
um I can tell you over the last 12 years
with both of my kids there's been
Seasons when my wife will say to me or I
will say to her
um this I would like to see this
different with our kid
and both of us have enough trust with it
with one another that we can at least
have
um I trust that you're right or I trust
at least it's worth another conversation
or I can say things like I don't like
where this the state of y'all's
relationship I'm gonna lean in for a
while and I'm gonna take this for a
season because your knee just needs to
be some space here
um and vice versa right and so
um that's that's as that's as much as I
want to get into it without going into
too many details none of it's bad or
silicious it's just us leaning on each
other and being willing to speak truth
to each other and so if I'm you
I would take my like the same advice I
give her but I would take him out and
say listen
um
you're losing your sons
and there's few things in the world more
important than a son's relationship to
his dad
your sons will chase his Blessing for
their entire life even if they hate him
they are desperate for him to hug them
they are desperate for them for him to
put his hands on the back of their neck
or hold their face and look him in the
eye and say I love you I'm glad you're
my son
they are desperate for that so desperate
that they will seek that in a million
different places
and they will chase and Chase and Chase
and Chase until their world is Ash
and I would speak that directly to him
and what it looks like is something as
simple as my son Hank and I go to
breakfast at Waffle House once a week
I do bedtimes with both my kids every
night
I treat their mother really well
I take my son with me places I try my
daughter doesn't like to always leave
the house but uh I I take them
everywhere I took my daughter to the
store with me the other day I take my
son with me places
I intentionally build in some time
because when you take a kid to the store
it takes another 45 minutes
and when I take my son fishing we're
gonna catch less fish all right because
I'm going to be untangling things and
whatever
um and so I'm just building that into my
life because
I love my kids and like you mentioned
you said it perfectly I'm raising young
adults right I've got a finite amount of
time and influence and but it's not even
about that it's about I love them and I
like spending time with them I would
have that conversation with your husband
in a very direct way
this needs to change
and what you have to be prepared for is
him to say no it's not going to
I don't like them they annoy me I don't
want them around me I don't know what
I'm doing
and he's gonna has a he has a right to
opt out
um that's becomes a pretty tough
character issue but you're gonna have to
here's what I'm saying you can't be a
peacemaker anymore you've got to put it
on the line and say something
and to answer your original question
um you always always always
protect the kids
always that's one of my core value rules
when it comes to working in these kind
of situations kids come first
thank you
you got real quiet on me no it's just a
lot to take in
um I think take me to that conversation
conversation why
yeah
because it I don't think it'll go over
well
because I don't well no I know that he
doesn't see a problem like whenever I've
told him before hey the you know one kid
has come to me and asked me to talk to
you about this one thing for them
because they're scared to or you know
they weren't comfortable with it like it
kind of brushes that off if that's silly
there's no reason they should feel
uncomfortable and that's where you stop
and say but they do
and they do because you don't ever talk
to them you never take them places you
have no input in their life other than
to make sure they're doing the things
that you said
the last time you hugged them and said I
love you I'm so grateful that out of all
the people in the world I got picked to
be your dad
you've said that zero times
that's why
and I'm just telling you right now
here's here's my promise to you Holly my
promise is this
avoiding this conversation is choosing
to pick
the illusion of stability
over the heartfelt reality that you
fought for your sons
when nobody else would
and I also am not naive
I know that some of these conversations
end very badly
but what I would tell you is that ending
will come sooner or later
whether you had this conversation or not
so you might as well have it
you'll want to be able to look at your
sons at some point if their dad abandons
them and say I went down swinging for
you guys
because you all deserve to have a dad
and he was struggling it wasn't y'all's
fault
I recommend doing this right to write
down what you want to say and be very
specific
don't say things like I feel and I feel
like that feelings are great and they're
important but they're easily dismissed
in these kind of conversations be very
specific
you haven't I haven't seen the boys are
desperate for they're avoiding you
they're scared of you here's the context
we've built and here's a couple of
things I'm asking you to start doing
tell our boys you love them every
freaking day
stop what you're doing close your
computer put your phone down and hug our
sons every day
every day ask them
what's the best part of your day
once a week take each one of them out to
breakfast you can do that once a week
take each one of them on a walk you can
do that
[Music]
and my hope is maybe just doesn't know
maybe he thinks they don't like him
maybe he's never seen this happen and
this is all weird and new because his
dad didn't talk to him fine
he's got to make a change he's about to
lose his two boys
uh 12 and a 14 year old are about to
head off into Woods without him
if they haven't already
thank you for loving them this is where
that love gets real hard
but they're lucky to have you as their
mom Holly
we'll be right back
deloney here and I've got a word from
this episode sponsor betterhelp let's
all be honest life would be way easier
if it came with a user manual marriage
parenting work making friends especially
as adults but this is the truth my
friends there's no step-by-step guide
you have to take ownership of your life
and when it feels like too much or you
feel stuck or overwhelmed it's too easy
to get lost in the anxiety black hole
I've been there but you can learn to
navigate this beautiful chaos we call
life in a healthy way therapy gives you
the tools to do just that and that's why
I love better help better help is online
therapy that offers video phone even
live chat sessions with your therapist
there's no waiting rooms no traffic no
endlessly searching for the right
therapist that happens to not take your
insurance listen better help is
connected more than three million people
with licensed therapists and they can
match you with a therapist under 48
hours so don't settle for feeling stuck
visit betterhelp.com com deloney today
to learn more and get 10 off your first
month that's betterhelp.com deloney
all right we're back Jack let's go to
rob in Miami Florida Welcome to Miami
what's up Rob what's going on Dr John
it's a privilege and an honor to be on
the best mental health uh and and
relationship podcast it's catching on
brother that's awesome thanks Rob what's
up dude how can I help man so uh my
question was uh how do I identify what
my needs are uh in relationship to
marriage relationships work Ministry Etc
dude that's a dope question all right so
how can you identify what your needs are
tell me more
so basically
um about two years ago I started the
journey into bettering my mental and
emotional health
and I realized
um I've never been asked
you know the question you always ask in
your podcast which is you know sit down
with your wife and ask what are your
needs these are my needs and uh I've
tried that with my wife and when she
asked me she's very straight to the
point hey I need you to clean this do
this I got the garbage and when she asks
me I just draw a blank I'm not used to
being asked what a news I'm used to
supply the needs ah man dude
you're an absolute Rock Star Rob
uh I was growing up hard or was it
um pretty smooth sailing
uh it was pretty tough yeah
you spent a lot of your life making sure
everybody else is all right
haven't you
correct yes sir okay
and there's honor and Valor in that and
there's Beauty in that and it's finite
because the longer you go without
changing the oil and without giving
yourself a checkup and without changing
the tires
the shorter the life is right and so
your ability to help others and to love
others and to do well for other people
is shortened if you don't take care of
yourself if you don't understand what
your needs are and ask for help in
meeting those things I can't tell you
how proud I am of you man
it's you're asking the million dollar
question and I'm so proud of you
um I also want to challenge your wife
and she's not on the phone so
she's given you a series of tasks
all right like a series of things that
she is like a honeydew list
I'm gonna suggest needs are deeper than
that okay
so here's the way
um you can find those needs here's all I
want you to do
get a small you have a like a like a
smartphone
yes all right cool just keep the notes
app on your phone open
and I want you to start writing down
when you get mad
when you get angry when you get sad when
you get frustrated right
your emotions are signals
and for you when you shut down I want
you to write that down
what just happened that makes you check
out that makes your body going to
neutral
what makes you want to hit somebody in
the mouth
what makes you want to just back up and
have another beer or back up and just
head out of the house because she's
going again or he's going to get
whatever's going on
your emotions are signals
and it's just simply learning to read
it's like you're in a new country and
you you don't know the language and you
see all these signs along the road and
you just need to learn what the signs
say that's what we're doing here okay
and your body is a great signaler and
most people in your situation have spent
their entire lives learning how to shut
those signals off
so they can just be about getting the
job done so people quit hassling them
is that fair
yes sir okay
when your body begins to say every time
somebody comes at me I shut down
that's a need
hey honey
whenever you get really mad at me I shut
down and I'm working on it
but if you need something from me I'm
gonna ask can you just write it down for
a season and put her on this little note
card for me
or when I come in the door and the first
thing you start doing is starting
rattling off 15 things I need to get
done today
I need you when we when I walk in the
door can you just
um holler at me and I'll come find you
and we can just hug for five seconds it
just helps calm me down a little bit
your hugs bring me peace be a gift to me
that's what I'm looking at okay or I
need 10 minutes when I walk in the door
just to transition from my job
to my home I just need 10 minutes can I
have 10 minutes
and those are where you start uncovering
what your needs are okay
and here's where it's going to get
really hard
a couple of them you're going to be
embarrassed about
you're going to feel ashamed of
like I did when I asked my wife hey
occasionally can you just tell me that
you're proud of me because I'm doing all
this for you
and that was embarrassing for me to say
out loud
um some men desperately need sex but
some men desperately need their wife
like the person who loves them just to
hold their hand
sit by him not ask for anything just be
with and that sounds very unmasculine it
sounds very like oh my gosh are you
serious yes I'm serious so whatever your
needs happen to be that's what they
happen to be hey can we just watch a
show together can we go for a walk
together right and the more you look
listen to your body send your signals
through these emotions these feelings
whatever
the closer you're gonna get to it
how's that sound
that sounds uh sounds good sounds uh
plain easy to follow yeah it is but
there's layers to it okay so there's
gonna come a season when you keep
thinking the floor is falling out from
under you
you're gonna think you've got it and
then you're going to get really mad
about something and it's that moment
when you can go ah okay what's my body
trying to tell me here
or you're gonna just get up to go get
another piece of cake or another donut
and then another donut you can ask
yourself okay what's my body trying to
tell me here I may just need some sleep
I may just need to go to exercise for 30
minutes or I may need to sit down and
have a hard conversation with my wife
that makes sense
yes sir and the next time y'all sit down
and have this conversation I'm dude I'm
so freaking proud of you for even having
this conversation
next time you sit down and she starts
rattling off I need you to paint this I
need you to get the dishes up I need you
to get get the trash taken out I want
you to say
excellent those are a series of tasks I
can do I can do those jobs
beneath that though sweetheart what do
you need from me
do you need me to be more present
you want me to work less
you need a shower more like what do you
need from me
because I'm gonna lean in and she's
going to give you a couple of needs
they're going to make you feel
uncomfortable and again that discomfort
that your body's sending you a signal
what is it what's your body trying to
tell you so this is a one two three year
Journey you're on now man to actually
start asking yourself what do I need and
here's what's really fun about needs
they shift and they change they move and
that makes them fun right when you think
you got them
you know what I need less touch in this
season I need more exercise you know I
need less exercise than season any more
sleep you know I need I need more just
let's go on dates I need less dates I
just need more wild rambunctious sex you
know what I need less crazy sex and I
need more boring married person sex just
straight up boring connectivity whatever
it looks like man it's getting in touch
with that cycle that you're gonna have
and needs and needs and needs and it
becomes such a fun adventure
to do with your spouse
so fun because her needs shift your need
shift and the goal becomes not trying to
hold those needs stable
but it becomes man how can I meet those
needs
that's a fun adventure man doesn't get
much more fun than that brother I'm
proud of you rob keep getting to know
yourself keep getting to know your wife
man y'all are in for a fun fun adventure
we'll be right back
hey guys deloney here and I've got a
word from our sponsor whoop if you've
listened to the show for any length of
time you know I'm a major nerd about
Fitness sleep mental health and building
healthier life habits and let's just say
this whoop makes my nerd heart so happy
one reason I love whoop is that it's not
like all the other fitness trackers that
mix in a watch in laser lights and
smiley faces and a million notifications
and reminders that you you need to get
your steps in no whoop is a fitness
wearable that actually looks cool and
it's comfortable and it gives you data
that really matters it breaks down your
recovery your sleep and your daily
strain into a format that's easy to
interpret and some days I wake up in the
green and this tells me that I'm ready
to go attack the day and other days I
wake up in the red and I know that I
gotta take it easy and I can look back
in time and see how I got there if
you're working to be intentional and
build healthier habits whoop can help
you get there start keeping an eye on
your health and wellness at a deeper
level go to whoop dot com that's
w-h-o-oop.com and use promo code deloney
to get 10 off your order today
all right we're back let's go to Diana
in Philadelphia uh what's up Diana
hi Dr John yes how's it going
oh you know It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia it's always except when the
Astros win the World Series so what's up
oh no uh thank you for the opportunity
for connecting today I know I recently
came across some of your work and I
appreciate everything you do so thanks
for the opportunity but I am you know
I'm calling today because I've been
struggling with an issue of essentially
not being comfortable with my fiance's
close work relationship with his female
manager okay
um how long have you all been together
uh we've been together now almost five
years five years okay how long has this
relationship been going on
between him and his boss
uh it's like it's like since the
pandemic but like what's really starting
to bother me is like they'll pass you
know two years or so so he switched
positions and so like the first part of
that was you know everybody was working
from home and it was back into the
office so it's kind of been manifesting
like the last you know one and a half to
two years
all right so what do you seeing that's
setting off your alarm systems
yeah so you know I'm like observing like
just changes and like his behavior and I
think like hold on what does that mean
is he like starting to unbutton his
shirt more is he like wearing deep V's
like uh yeah like oh gross don't get any
saving more savings
all right yeah if he starts wearing deep
V's that's just the sign you're done
this thing's not gonna it's not gonna
last okay good
um okay so he's being more hygienic what
else yeah uh you know I I noticed like
some inconsistencies so I guess the
other layer to this is we also work
together at the same company
so dude you gotta lead with that one so
you're watching this happen I'm watching
it happen yes
so yeah we work together and we're not
same Department not even the same office
using a different part of the city even
but so like you know we know each
other's jobs we know each other's
backgrounds I'm in a little bit higher
leadership position at the company so it
makes it complex because I don't want to
mix professional with personal but you
know this kind of merges here
um it's Diana it's already mixed
yes yeah so let's just call it what it
is it's mixed you work you work with a
guy that is beneath you positionally and
I couldn't have said that more awkward
and you're dating him for a long time
and now he
something about that relationship is
that something okay is it something you
know about her or is it something you
know about him
or is it are you watching this thing
happen or do you just not like another
woman having this type of power over him
because she's his boss
yeah I think for me it's like I'm
observing things it's the travel it's be
like not returning text it's not being
able to answer my call when he's on
business it's the sharing of the rental
vehicles it's you know like the stories
where you know well the whole group's
going down but then it's like three
people and not six you know or you know
Well everybody's sharing the carb and
it's just them you know so and it's like
I know all this this because like I with
an earshot you know way
so it's it's all that that bothers me
you know because like when we're
together any other time it's like we
have good communication we have a very
healthy relationship like
um but it's like when he's on travel I
can tell that it's like well you know
nine to five I'm working and then we're
all going to dinner and then they go to
the bar till 10 30 at night and you know
he will call me but it's like very
distant or you know there's times where
like he won't answer the phone
um you know if they're all at breakfast
in the morning and then he'll say it's
like well it's rude to answer when
you're talking to somebody else and I'm
like well it's me you know so things
like that
foreign
so this is oh man
I'm only talking to you here okay
yes and that's what I need
yeah this sounds a lot like your problem
not his
yeah and here's why
um I think he's right if you're having
like breakfast with work colleagues to
sit there at the at the table and here
here's
it sounds like he is out traveling doing
work
and you want to have the same
relationship the same communication the
same
um
the same
yeah communication patterns that you
have in in when he's there in person and
you simply can't
and I think it is patently unwise to
travel all over the country like yes he
is playing with fire let's make no
mistake about it no question about that
okay I think it's unwise okay
I just think it's unwise
um
and so I think that's worthy of a
conversation both professionally and
personally in your relationship but this
doesn't sound like no dude she's always
draped all over him or she sends him a
bunch of emoji texts in the middle of
the night or he's got a special private
joke collection with her he doesn't have
with me like I'm not hearing any of that
I'm hearing yes
they're both putting themselves in
positions that are uniformly dumb in
today's world it's just dumb right
um
but I hear more I expect him to call me
back when he's working
well he maybe he can't or I expect him
to get up and leave a breakfast or a
dinner and see what I'm saying
look yeah no let me ask more
specifically why haven't y'all set up a
time hey right when you wake up call me
I want to be the first call when you
wake up
yeah have y'all set that up
yeah I mean it's hit and miss like
sometimes he'll do that he'll go to the
gym and he'll call me but like the other
thing that has made me I feel like more
uncomfortable too is that
um you know like there'll be times where
like there they work side by side every
day in the office uh typically prior to
like the pandemic
um we're lucky we're in a hybrid
situation now and they're like the only
ones typically
um in that section of their office so
like you know we'll he'll call me you
know at lunch time to say how's your day
going and then you know I'll hear her in
the background or she'll ask like who
you know he's talking to and like there
has been times where like he wouldn't
even end the call with and I love you
because he didn't want you know he would
say oh well I didn't want them to know
him on a personal call
and but I'm like that's like silly
because like that's like an unrealistic
expectation that you can never take a
personal call and it's not like it's
over excessive
so like it like that's like hurtful like
it almost feels to me like
he was trying to segregate like my his
relationship with me from like his work
relationship
um at science
so here's the best thing you can do
moving forward
you can be very very honest with him in
less in an accusatory way you're doing
this and you're doing this
but a very vulnerable
make this all your problem not his
yeah here's how I and I have I have
approached it like that and like that's
where you know I have been
um you know like trying to like go down
that route and be like listen I know uh
you know I I admit to like even in my
pre I did have infidelity in my previous
marriage and um that wasn't like the
deal breaker so I feel like I am
hypersensitive
um him and I were you know co-workers
before we were even together so like the
realism the whole work life thing you
know it's real but at the same time like
I would never tell him you can never
talk to another woman or you always have
to drop everything for me like I don't
feel that way like I I have to
um be able to interact in society and I
would never say quit your job because I
don't like someone you know but it's at
the point where when I do try to talk
about it and you know take
accountability like he'll just get super
angry and then like his anger then like
fuels me to think like well is there
some truth to it so you you are you are
absolutely right yeah absolutely right
there yeah a conversation my wife and I
had recently was
um I told her
I want to talk more on the phone
with you and the kids when I'm traveling
and what I realized was she was trying
to really be uh the most supportive
spouse she could be and that was man I
don't want to call you if you're on
stage I've been in the wings about to go
on stage and she's called and I've taken
the call just because I just think
that's fun and she can hear the crowd
she's like what are you doing it's like
I'm about to go on stage and she's like
oh my gosh get off the phone and or my
kids have calling me as I as I'm walking
into an interview for a radius right so
she has in an attempt to love me better
minimized phone calls she doesn't want
to bother me she's and so I said hey I I
wanna I need more contact on the road if
I call you we know that I'm trying to
reach out I'm gonna connect if you get a
moment just call I'd love it when you
call and if I can't take it I won't take
it and so here's the deal she was trying
to love me the best she could and then I
was able to say hey here's what my need
is in this season and it might be that
one day I'm like hey I need you to call
less like I've it's just too wild on the
road right now
um and so all to say is this
you can just speak your needs as you
need them and I don't like that he's
getting all mad and angry and frustrated
that is that would set off my alarms too
but here's the deal you can't control
that you have to make a choice
and you've been burned again before
you're starting to feel like you're
getting burned again
and I would trust your feelings and I
would trust those alarm systems that are
going off
I would also be very very real I would
ask my uh demand evidence from my
feelings is the way I'll say it
is he cheating is he about to cheat is
he getting pretty in close to cheating
or is it my alarms to people cheating
going off and those don't have to be
mutually exclusive but here's the deal
at the end of the day you got to make a
choice
and if you go through this relationship
you go into it I can hear it on you
you feel like you're losing it
you're gonna get married and you're
going to find yourself in another mess
again
less because you have a husband that or
a fiance that as a boss is a woman
more so you said hey here's what I'm
struggling with here's some of my needs
and he got pissed
yeah exactly like I'm more disappointed
in the fact that like he you know went
in just even say I'm Chasing Ghosts
right I control that like but the fact
that he just wouldn't honor
um and at least like just say hey you
know I get how you're feeling and let's
talk through this or is there some
Middle Ground I mean I even went to the
point where it's like like you said I
take accountability maybe I'm I'm wrong
and so I'm like maybe I you know maybe
we meet if she's important to you I want
her to be important to me and that's
fair I mean there's other people that
you know we have common friends other
co-workers other female co-workers
um and like even the first time I met
her it was like very awkward like she
wouldn't even introduce herself me for
the first five minutes I had to
introduce myself I've extended the olive
branch I said hey I know you know I
Mentor a lot of different people in in
our company I've invited her to come
have coffee with me
um you know participate with training
session with my team and she's really
always been standoffish and it's like
even I would feel better if you know I'd
call and I did hear her in the
background she's like oh you know say
tell Diane I said hi you know things
like that but it's it's very it's very
like hard for me to feel the Comfort but
she doesn't owe me anything I feel like
I'm more disappointed and slightly
betrayed with him are you done you know
with the relationship
okay the things you're now you're
telling me
the way she responds to you
um the way he responds when you bring
things up
I think you're right
I think you're right
I think your intuition's right and
earlier in this call I said this is your
your problem to deal with it is but I
think your intuition's right
something's not okay
right
and um
yeah like I feel like doing because you
mentioned like having that like
evidence-based it's like you know I feel
like it's not like that full-fledged
Affair I feel it's just like now you're
now you're guessing and you're hoping
I'm guessing I'm guessing and I'm hoping
you're guessing you're hoping
yes because you don't think
psychologically and spiritually and
emotionally you can handle another
somebody else cheating on you
Maybe
[Music]
mm-hmm
and so here's your path forward it's not
a pretty one
um
it's a pretty direct conversation with
him
and before I had that conversation with
them I would be very very specific about
your needs
and man if somebody feels awkward saying
I love you at the office I I'm okay with
that it's fine I don't want to be weird
um
that sounds like a strange work
environment but so be it
um
I
be very specific here's what I need from
you moving forward
and before that conversation okay let me
back up here
you only have one path forward and it's
going to be very uncomfortable and it's
going to be you directly asking are you
having an affair are you cheating on me
and this isn't a time for Rage or
um
uh
he's got to have a safe place where he
can tell the truth
the rage will come
Madness and anger will come
but this needs to be a safe factual
conversation are you having an affair
and if he gets mad and throws a fit say
I'm going to end this conversation right
now because you're not having this
conversation like an adult and we'll
Circle back and have this tomorrow
but I need you to be honest with me
I need you to have enough dignity and
respect for me
just as a person
as your friend as somebody you say
you've loved some I've been with for
five years just tell me if you're having
an affair tell me
this is a moment to not be a coward a
moment attack character and if you're
not having an affair
and you want to continue to be with me
and you want to get married to me and
spend the rest of our lives together
here's what I need
and you've got to be real specific and
the reason this is going to be gnarly
Diana is he might say yes I am having an
affair
he might say I haven't had an affair but
I've got feelings for my boss
he might say no I'm not having an affair
and the fact that you are are accusing
me uh makes me want to be with you
anymore
all those things can happen and the only
the only
offering of light I can give you in that
moment is that was gonna that was gonna
come crashing down at some point and
it's better to do it now before you are
legally married
my hope is he says I'm so sorry no I'm
not cheating on you never have
I don't know how to act in this work
environment it's weird
and I'm trying to be a good employee I
also want to be a good
um fiance to you I want to build a life
together I'm just kind of over my head I
know what to do and you as a woman who's
higher up in the company than he is who
has had men reporting to you you can
walk through here's what's appropriate
here's what's not here's what it's okay
for you to say and here's what's not
um
and go from there but there's no way
forward doesn't really Direct
really direct hard on the nose
conversations no beating around the bush
no like well I've been thinking about
are you cheating on me I need to know
and I deserve at least that much and if
not and you still want to be with me
be very clear what I need moving forward
and tell me what you need moving before
work on this together
I'm so sorry Dan hey let me know how
that conversation goes I want to know
what he says and where things stand
we'll be right back
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right we are back in honor of
Kelly's big neck tattoo that she got
recently you can't see it because of her
hair she's got a big tattoo of Elvis
Presley uh his face
um young Elvis by the way not old Elvis
young Elvis looks good it's a good I
would have got on my neck but it looks
good
um in honor of her new tattoo today's
song of the day is Elvis Presley's
Suspicious Minds
hmm it goes like this we're caught in a
trap I can't walk out because I love you
too much baby why can't you see what
you're doing to me when you don't
believe a word I say we can't go on
together with suspicious minds and we
can't build our dreams on Suspicious
Minds so if an old friend I know stops
by to say hello but I still see
suspicion in your eyes
you can't see these tears are real I'm
crying yes I'm crying
lucky for you all Kelly she never cries
we'll see you soon
[Music]